I  I have been skiing since I was 4 years  old my name is Claudio and I ski over  volcanoes I spent most part of a year  close to the mountain when I spend time  away from it  I feel nostalgic like something is  missing to my soul to my life and in  this moment I take my ski and I go up  Mount Etna is located on the east coast  of Sicily  is a known as the tallest and active  work on in the Europe the risk depending  on tightener are the same of any other  mountain  you have to be careful and respect what  is surrounding us  the view from the top is unique you can  see the landscape change many times from  cream woods to desert volcanic area all  the lava flow and the cost black powder  is volcanic sand and its format during  the eruption it's incredible  you  but I bother him